oh hello there I'm Abbey shark
welcome to toilet talk where I help you
build a better relationship with your
porcelain crapper now before we get too
far into things I've got a question here
for my friend Cathy Dear Abby my
neighbor told me that ever since he
started drinking kombucha her bowel
movements have been on fleek and she
sets us all because of the probiotics
everywhere I turn I see throw this plea
that Biot exists and she be belly
dancers are telling me that I need more
in my diet I'm tired of pretending like
I know what this means I have to admit
my toilet game could use some
improvement and if I can change anything
in my diet and help me out I'm on board
well Cathy we've all been there
and you know I am your go to toilet guru
but before you go and buy a buttload of
kombucha and sing Kumbaya with your
buddies let's talk so first of all what
the heck are probiotics well our guest
house is a wide range of bacteria and a
large proportion of affect here are what
we considered good bacteria take a
probiotics and these good probiotic
bacteria are really important for
maintaining overall good health and so
there's a lot of great research out
there to support probiotics and here are
some of the great ways that probiotics
are important for your health
early research suggests that probiotics
may play a role in everything from
reducing the risk of years without
disease lactose intolerance headaches
anxiety depression and promoting heart
health bone health immunity irregularity
and blood sugar control we're really
just scratching the surface trying to
understand all the amazing ways that
probiotics play a role in promoting
health so I'm personally always just
trying to stay on top of all the
research so where do we find probiotics
well naturally we want to look for
fermented foods so fermentation is the
process where we convert sugars into
gases acids and alcohols as a way to
preserve
so in the process to get a whole range
of beneficial enzymes and probiotics
easily out of that so some of my
favorite examples of fermented foods are
things like yogurt tofu sauerkraut
pickles wine beer and copy your neighbor
favorite kombucha now keep in mind that
all foods have calories and things like
beer and wine of course should be
enjoyed in moderation but try to get
your probiotics from a nice wide range
of foods so you really can complement
your overall diet and system nicely in
Tuesday so then what about prebiotics
because I know they sound similar but
they're not prebiotics sets the stage
for got help they're actually part of
certain foods that we don't actually
digest so they feed the gut bacteria and
help them actually do their job so some
of my favorite examples of posters of
prebiotic foods like bananas onions
leeks garlic soy beans asparagus
sunchokes artichokes and chicory roots
so when you think about prebiotics and
probiotics you want to think of them as
a team like Batman and Robin or Bonnie
and Clyde or jay-z and Beyonce so
beyonce is pretty much rocket ecology
but you know let's think about this
prebiotics are the trusty sidekick that
make probiotics all the more of that'
and make your get a rock star so next
time you're driving to yogurt add some
banana in there for a little prebiotic
action to get the party started you'll
be in good shape so Kathy I hope you're
no longer confused and definitely more
importantly no longer constipated now
you've got some ideas on how to
incorporate prebiotics and probiotics
foods into your diet now for the rescue
guys if you loved this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some of your burning toilet
all questions and of course subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen